le pass vaccinale et neil alfani l'oméga
vous avez raison c'est une mesure
supplémentaire qui vient s'ajouter et
qui sera à notre disposition si jamais
si jamais il devait y avoir de nouveaux
variants émergents nécessitant de
garantir un niveau de protection
optimale et vous le savez je le redis sa
mort ça va de soi c'est une évidence
mais parfois les évidences doivent être
rappelés tous ceux qui ces outils de
passes sanitaire de passes vaccinale le
jour on en a plus besoin le jour où nous
sommes plus sous la menace permanente
d'un nouveau variant nous en passeront
avec beaucoup de plaisir et même
beaucoup de regrets vous comme moi sur
la liste des organisations je vous savez
que je ne vais pas revenir je conteste
formellement le chiffre de 20% de lits
fermés à l'hôpital et toutes les études
ont montré en revanche oui l attention à
l'hôpital et la fatigue des heures sup
qui n'ont pas été prises des démissions
qui aurait dû être prise l'année
dernière mais qui n'ont pas été prises
parce que les soignants se sont dit
c'est pas le moment de partir quand ça
tape il faut qu'on reste et on partira
plus tard vous avez des des heures
supplémentaires qui ont été accumulées
jusqu'à ce que les soignants depuis ce
plus d'accumuler parce que ça faisait
quand même beaucoup trop pour eux ils
sont extrêmement courageux d'ailleurs je
le dis parce que on parle peut-être
moins d'attention hospitalière
maintenant qu'elle est d'installer qu
avant qu'elle ne s'installe mais elle
est vive 21 mille malades dans les
hôpitaux c'est beaucoup 3800 patients
dans les réanimations pour duke au vide
c'est cette intense le nom de
déprogrammation dans notre pays a des
conséquences sur la santé des français
c'est pourquoi une pousse on vraiment à
la vaccination c'est aussi dans cet
objectif de ne pas
obérer toutes les chances pour des
patients qui ne sont pas là pour le coc
vide et qui n'ont rien demandé et qui
veulent juste être soignés en temps et
en heure de pouvoir être soigné et qu'on
soit obligés de garder des places de
réanimation dans l'hypothèse où des
patients non vaccinés viendrait atteint
par le cos vide
[Musique]